okay now this is sort of funny but some
people are furious why because people
are furious about everything these days
bomb throwing right wing radio host rush
limbaugh quoted me yesterday he actually
read one of my tweets
and it was one of the tweets i sent
during
the stream of the first night of the
democratic national convention
at the time i didn't think it was going
particularly well because it wasn't
so i'm going to play the clip of rush
for you then i will talk about the
reaction
from some on the left to this and just
how completely misguided
and and missing the boat some people are
about this let's look at russia's clip
first
david pakman political tv
radio show host tweeted someone please
talk me off the ledge
i want to win the first 22 minutes of
this convention i am
scared can somebody tell me how great
this is or something can somebody make
me feel better
didn't start well okay so the exact
tweet that he read he added a paraphrase
at the end which is make me feel better
i didn't actually tweet that
i tweeted 22 minutes into night one
quote
someone please talk me off the ledge i
want to win
and the first 22 minutes of this dnc i'm
scared
can someone tell me how great this is or
something now
later on it improved and i said it did
particularly with michelle obama's
speech at the end of the night and night
two was
significantly better than night one
overall but
here's what i want to talk about with
you um i mentioned earlier and yesterday
that some people on the left were mad at
me they were even furious at me
i even had a few cancellations for lack
of a better term
because i was criticizing the first part
of night one of the dnc
and there were people on the left
reacting
with you know this feeling of how does
david have the audacity to criticize
what the dnc is doing
that i'm the problem because i'm
pointing out
that i don't like some of this stuff and
i'm being mean
and i'm not being supportive enough of
removing donald trump or being a team
player or whatever
that is exactly the bs
garbage tone policing gatekeeping
nonsense that leads us to losing and
some people said david
when you tweeted that you literally
created fodder for the right
in the sense that rush limbaugh then
read your tweet
but the dnc was not going well at that
point in time i didn't like what i saw
the right was going to say it was
terrible no matter what
so it wouldn't make a difference in that
sense because the right is going to come
out and say this is terrible and what an
embarrassment and blah blah blah i said
what i believe to be going on and you
know what later on it improved and i
said so
i'm not saying it improved because of
what i said
but who gains anything from me lying to
you
and saying wow this is really great this
is this is going so well and so when i
see these comments
oh you ended up supporting republican
talking points
by tweeting that no i reacted genuinely
that's the promise that's the premise
and the promise
of this program my commitment here is
not always to say
what you think it's not to be on board
with whatever is the orthodoxy of the
democratic party i'm not even a democrat
remember
the reason people watch the live streams
and the content
is to get my honest and immediate
reactions to what's going on
what do we gain if i do political
theater where i say you know this is
crap
but it would look bad if i say that so
i'm going to pretend that this is great
and lie to my audience like is that
actually what people are suggesting i
should do because rush limbaugh read one
of my tweets
the fact that limbaugh read a tweet
is no more evidence of anything than the
fact that
hitler breathing oxygen says anything
about oxygen more broadly if you
understand the point
that i'm making alluding to an ad
hominem fallacy here and so
we really gain nothing by scolding
people
who are making what are honest critiques
and we actually i would make the case
lose
a lot when we do this tone policing and
attempting to regulate
what counts as acceptable commentary and
i was
out of line apparently with what is
really a pretty milk toast tweet guys i
mean in the end
this tweet is nothing's hinging on this
tweet so
i think it's interesting i don't know
exactly how my tweet
made it to rush limbaugh now years ago
rush limbaugh did a whole
segment where he refers to this program
and a segment we did multiple times
without calling it by name
and so we know that somehow over time
clips have gotten to rush limbaugh i
don't know how this got to him quite
frankly but
somehow it did um but uh listen
if if you want a show that will just
always praise what the democratic party
is doing
i'm sure those shows exist it's just not
this one okay
and so i'm not apologizing and i will
continue to call it like it is
august 23rd is the 15th anniversary of
the david pakman show
we will be doing a huge membership
special if you want to be notified about
it
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
august 23rd email will go out telling
you how to take advantage
of what we hope will be the biggest
single day surge in memberships in david
pakman show history
and of course remember that you can get
the podcast on
any app you like spotify stitcher google
play
itunes pandora if that is your gig
get the daily audio podcast take it with
you
every single day